um in both information science and also
affiliated with computer science
um today i want to talk to you about
ai and humanity on the ground um a bit
of a context i am a designer i design
human ai in action um what does that
mean i
don't invent ai algorithms
but i take the latest algorithmic
advances from ar research and see what
kind of thing we can build
um and i also don't um don't develop
ethics or social science theories but i
take
research from those communities and see
what are the potential harms that we
need to consider when we design these
applications and we put these
applications in real-world context and
see what additional lessons we can learn
can feed back to those communities so
today i want to give you i want to spend
some time on
one specific case study and from there i
want to talk about some
lessons we learned in the process
with regard to ai and humanity
this is from quite a few years back a
group of biomedical engineering
researchers came to talk to us and they
want to build an ai that helps
with one of their most difficult
clinical decisions that is
whether and when to implant an end stage
heart failure patients with an
artificial heart
artificial heart is a mechanical pump
that you put into the patient's heart
and pumps the blood for them when people
have really severe heart diseases there
is a tube coming out of the patient's
body linking to an external battery and
the patient will need to carry that
battery and take care of the wand for
the remainder of their
their lives
as you as you can imagine there's huge
medical risks associated with this open
heart surgery and recovery and also it
involves a huge lifestyle change you'd
better remember to charge that battery
as in many other end-of-life decisions
it is the doctor's job to decide um to
identify patients who are most likely to
benefit from this treatment people who
are sick enough to even you know make
sense to to to do such an invasive
and an aggressive treatment on the
patient and um but also the patient
should not be too sick otherwise they
cannot survive the open-heart surgery
so there's this very tricky task of
identifying this right window of
sickness and white right time to implant
and this is a very difficult decision
um so the idea is that machine learning
can help if we have
um almost about a decade of data about
the outcome of previous implant patients
um the idea is that if we can learn what
kind of
features what kind of factors that can
predict better treatment outcome
then we can systematically identify
people who are most likely to benefit
from the treatment these systems um
here's a screenshot from
such a system from 2008 and i have to
say systems today look roughly the same
so
you put in a list of patient variables
in electronic medical records and then
you click enter and you see
predictions of
the likely outcome
of this surgery
now
over the years we have research has
repeated show uh showed that doctors
don't use this kind of system among the
many buttons and many functions in
electronic medical records this is the
least used one
not an easy
achievement to to reach um and a common
complaint is that their experiences are
better than ai
and i think i think they have a really
good point um
one of the things when we work with
those doctors
the doctors are often asked is
are these outcomes are these previous
outcomes based on my best effort you
know i performed less well if i had a
fight with my wife last night
um and this kind of nuances might be
very strange for us for people who build
ai systems but for doctors they really
know it they know all the limitations of
the data set
on top on top of that and
they know there are limitations of the
ai so they really resisted this kind of
systems
so our goal is just trying to find that
kind of middle ground like how can we
make these systems useful knowing that
there have been problems among the
doctors like human decisions um but also
to to understand
um how these um how they can complement
each other so we went to three hospitals
across the u.s and we spend about 14
full days in their advanced heart
failure programs observing how these
clinicians take care of patients and
make decisions
um
i think well we found many barriers that
would prevent this ai from being useful
um
but one of the key
takeaway for us was
there is just really a lot of human
messiness in that decision
i'll give you one example so one of the
clinical guideline
guidelines is that
the patient should be given more
consideration
if they have a spouse if they have
someone who can
um who can take care of them in this
recovery process of the open heart
surgery um so the doctors will be
struggling with for example
i know this patient is about to have a
divorce but on paper this person is
still married so it actually meets the
standard to to to have this to to be
eligible for this treatment do i tell it
tell them or not these are the very
human decisions that the doctors try to
make and the way they make this decision
is not that let me see whether this fits
the guideline or not or what how ethical
it is to you know to to
manipulate a little bit about that
person's marital relationship instead
they're thinking how can i save this
patient this is a last stop treatment if
i say no
these patients go through palliative
care so for them the decision is not
really to consider eligibility they're
considering do i have a better
alternative if no
maybe i should just try it regardless
how high the risk this treatment is so
in dealing with all these very messy
conditions
what we found is doctors almost never
make decisions in front of a computer
they always make decisions especially
the difficult ones through conversations
i put this image because i cannot take
any photo in my healthcare empirical
work
but this is really what the doctors
meeting reminded me of they're like four
chandeliers over your head there is no
big projectors like this because in our
environment discussions are centered
around computers but for the doctors the
decisions are all centered around
human beings and the human beings are
the clinicians in this case are very are
working in a very hierarchical
organization people who
are attending physicians people who have
the power to sign up
clinical decisions set on one end of the
table and then you sit according to
ranks so people who the social workers
the nurse practitioners
um the interns who actually
take care of the patient in and out
almost 24 hours a day those people sit
on the very far end of the table and
they don't get
much to say in the meaning even though
they really have very sort of felt
understanding of what this patient
condition has been
so with all these insights in mind
we
started to consider a different kind of
ai um
so the idea is that instead of thinking
about our ai as something that can
inform the decision of implant or no
implant itself we want to think about ai
as something
that provides
like one component of that decision so
um here is the model we end up
retraining um
instead of predicting whether you should
or should not implant your or or
survival um
the the the
longevity um at post surgery we predict
the likelihood of every adversarial
event um
what does the chance of um renal failure
look like does that have all kinds of
implications
for not only
the implant
eligibility but also the quality of life
of that patient
and we embedded this machine learning
prediction it's in a corner here um
into this meeting slide
the idea is that on this slide every
component represents one facet of that
patient's condition here's some medical
history here's that person's financial
evaluation here's a person's
psychosocial evaluation maybe there is a
clinical note about that person's
marital status as well um the idea is
that ai is really not trying to be
at the front and center instead it's
just one another piece of information
that you should consider in the clinical
care process um
one doctor puts it very elegantly like
ai would just be
a blood test or an x-ray in the future
no doctor makes a decision solely based
on blood tests or solely based on
an x-ray result
it's always the big picture but that's
but just like x-ray and just like blood
test ai is a really important component
in this
we tested this system across three
hospitals in the u.s at different three
hospitals
and and we really found um
really encouraging results doctors
really embrace these predictions and
they actually use the ai
discuss spend a lot of time deliberating
what the ai means how much can you trust
a prediction versus a fact where i mean
everything in clinical
decision making is about you know
clinical trials and causal effects like
how do we deal with this prediction
so that elaboration was really helpful
and also it provides a lot of vigilance
for the people who sit at the far end of
that long table they can say hey doctor
i don't agree with you here is an ai
that also says well they don't need to
say i don't agree with it they can say
hey doctor why don't why do you think
the ai you know says this and so it
triggers a social conversation and in
that sense it's really
um it really provided more perspectives
in that discussion
we have evidence that this kind of
message um and this kind of design this
idea that ai being one faces of clinical
decision really generalizes to all kinds
of
um
complex clinical decisions that involve
multiple organs or usually involves
multiple groups of clinicians
and here is just another quick case
study where this is a collaboration with
google brain and google health where we
apply the exact same message to
cancer diagnosis on pathology slides by
the way this is how a clinical best
practice looks like this is what the
doctors are making your cancer diagnosis
based on really you know beautiful art
um
and we found that doctors make these
decisions really based on gut reaction
they can
they can diagnose they can see cancer on
that slide which is only twice as large
as our actual cells and they can see
cancer from there so that really sort of
instinctive
um image recognition skill when
complemented by ai we can improve the
cancer diagnosis
accuracy by about 30 percent so that's a
really encouraging
result
and i also want to mention other
scholars work that
over time have discovered similar
patterns in other
critical domains like civic uh
civil litigation and
artists working with language models and
so on so forth
what does this all mean
um
i want to share three
ideas i think are really mainly for
provocations i'm curious what you guys
all think
um
point number one
i think when we discuss the
imperfections of ai we should always
talk about them
side by side with human limitations
just like human beings data and the ai
built upon it always captures humanities
or always capture human needs
in a quite partial and quite reductive
way
but that's the same as how doctors make
decisions they cannot possibly think
about
every possible phases of the situation
in order to make decisions you have to
be reflective in some way
so
i think
it's relatively fine in a lot of cases
it's fine for ai to be partial and
reductive
but the key is that we recognize these
limitations we recognize how these ais
are partial and are reductive and
deliberate
these limitations alongside with the
human perspectives as long as there is
this deliberation most often we can get
good results as shown in all the case
studies i mentioned earlier
but then here comes a real new question
i think the real challenge of making ai
like accounting for ai's unintended
consequences is really people's limited
attention um i think it is not a
coincidence that some of the most
damaging ai outcomes come from seemingly
trivial things like social media reading
social media feeds youtube videos where
you see cute cat videos
rather than medicine
law these seemingly really you know
remarkable places that is because
doctors and lawyers and so forth spend a
lot of time deliberating um
they recognize the ai's limitations and
when they are open enough to use it they
know how to put it in perspective
with their own pers uh where's their
personal understandings
but in a lot of other cases people don't
have the attention people don't
deliberate or people cannot even imagine
how the ai can be wrong and i think
those are the places that are really
dangerous
one last point um
i think we're living in a society where
deliberating on each and every one each
and every ai is becoming increasingly
impossible um
we um our group currently does a lot of
work in text generation and writing
among everyday people not artists so
people who don't have the time to
deliberate on each whether each ai
suggestion mean
and for people who work on platform tags
where
like think about google search that has
which has more than a thousand ai
systems running in the background you
cannot deliberate on each limitation of
each ai and that
makes it really hard for us to think
about human ai complementarity think
about how you can make this process
deliberative and thoughtful and how can
we prevent biases in these contexts are
the real challenge for
our next step
thank you